hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video bzw nicht wie lockt
sondern heute eher so eine art hall oder
hope powell habe keine ahnung das heißt
wenn man so sachen vorstellen man sich
gekauft hat ich werde nichts mehr
tutorial also ich würd kleine sachen
hier vorstellen die ich mit klamotten
gekauft habe sondern mediamarkt sachen
weil wir natürlich auf einem gaming
kanal sind werde ich das mit mediamarkt
sachen machen ich war nämlich in köln
beziehungsweise auch in düsseldorf und
auch bei uns ihrer region in einem
media-markt und natürlich nicht im mai
sondern auch in anderen geschäften aber
halt auch wegen universität zwecken also
unis angeguckt wohnung anguckt alles
mögliche gemacht
allgemein über die städte informiert ich
wollte auch papa erkannte köln bzw
nicht angesprochen aber auch so hensel
dorf auch also das war schon sehr witzig
wie ich kommen aber zwar immer noch
nichts mit klar dass ich zwar kam der
dah keine ahnung muss man halt mit leben
mit der zeit jedenfalls war ich bei
media markt in verschiedenen städten und
hab mir überall so ein paar sachen
zusammen gekauft habe jetzt endlich so
die sachen zusammen ich wollte mir noch
einen ich sag euch am ende einfach noch
was ich mir kaufen möchte und wollt euch
das jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen
vorstellen dass ich mir gekauft hat und
zwar fange ich erst mal mit den kleinen
sachen an wo ich gerade schon was hat
liegen lassen uns von intenze usb stick
gekauft würden mit 16 gb
weil jetzt habe ich endlich ein ich
hatte noch nie einen richtigen eigenen
usb-stick
ich habe ihnen wie man den von meinem
vater oder von meiner schwester genommen
da irgendwie sowas oder wenn wir die
anderen filme gegeben haben oder ich
wollte andere nehmen was geben habe ich
mal gesagt gib mir ein usb stick und was
alles deswegen aber jetzt endlich nur
mäßig 16 gigabyte
dann hab ich mir hier itunes 15 euro
also ganz simplen sachen dann habe ich
mir endlich einen zweiten hier damit
jetzt nicht an fokussieren wir auf mich
fokussiert ist aber wir hatten endlich
mal habe ich jetzt ein zweiter canon eos
600d akku mir geholt das ist so wichtig
gewesen für mich weil immer als ich mit
im aufgenommen habe wobei ich habe jetzt
eine webcam gekauft und ist jetzt
relativ unnötig aber wenn ich jetzt
irgendwo bin und irgendwie lange
erzählen muss was sich eventuell auch in
meinem studium später oft machen muss
habe ich jetzt endlich mal einen zweiten
akku also dass auf jeden fall sehr geil
dann kommen jetzt erst mal zu einer
sache die ich gerade schon auf meiner
kamera oben drauf hab erst manchmal beim
pisa und ich hatte eine face camp drin
was ich wollte ich habe fest im
aufgenommen bei verbier grad gesehen
habt allerdings ich hab das vergessen
rüberzuziehen das ist halt noch auf
meine kamera und ich habe darauf
vergessen
vor allem geht es um die aufnahme so ja
hier in der face kann sieht man gerade
blabla und eine französin ist diffus
kämen des trainingscamps
naja das ist gerade auf meiner kamera
drauf das ist eine rote video mike und
zwar gab es da zwar noch eine bessere
variante die in besseren kopfschutz hat
beziehungsweise besseren schutz also das
ist noch einen weiteren radius gut
aufgenommen wird allerdings hat meine
jetzt die ich hier oben drauf habe die
hat 119 euro gekostet und das andere 190
gekostet habe ich gesagt das war dass
wenn wir das nicht so gefällt gucke ich
mal dass andere besser ist weil der typ
ist alles korrekt kannst du machen und
dann was ich mir heute noch kauft war
einmal jetzt auch endlich battlefield 3
ja ich hab's für pc aber auf dem pc habe
ich nie so mit freunden gespielt ich
kein papier sehr viele freunde die es
wirklich auf der ps3 spielen deswegen
jetzt endlich mal für ps3 geholt ich
meine 25 euro ist echtes schnäppchen
neben 29 euro 90 ist immer noch ein
schnäppchen für battlefield 3 fans gehen
ich weiß bald komplett 44 aus aber ich
werde nicht battlefield 4 höher von auch
nicht call of duty seiner erstmal gta 5
und wie crew von dieses rennspiel oder
und fifa 14 auf jeden fall und dann habe
ich drei spiele und die kosten
bestimmten 180 euro 63 euro deswegen
habe ich dann erstmal kein geld mehr für
spiele sondern lasst dann erstmal kein
call of duty battlefield und warte
erstmal ab was die anderen leute
sozusagen nicht auf dauer ist und jetzt
das worauf alle gewartet haben
eine face ski bzw eine webcam und zwar
die lifecam hd 5000 es gab an die hd
3000 jetzt fünf euro weniger gekostet
ich dachte die kostet mehr und das ist
5000 dann irgendwas mehr
deswegen habe ich jetzt die einfach
geholt meine fünf euro das ist so eine
kleine webcam dies sehr klein also wenn
ihr das jede mal mit so einem loch
vielleicht was ich so mache und mit
meinen augen sind dies unglaublich klein
die stelle stand einfach so auf meinem
bildschirm drauf also ich kann das hier
so biegen einmal hier so ich kann das
auch jetzt obigen andersrum
und ja dann kann ich dir halt oben
einfach stellt die dann wahrscheinlich
so auf mein laptop auf meinem pc drauf
aber ich mach wahrscheinlich wieder
seine fans kennen die nicht so ist also
was ich zeig' seiner bin ich stand
geschafft die nicht so ist sondern die
dann so ist das im moment zeigen
ich gucke dass sie dann so halt ein
bisschen seitliches profil halt weiß
nicht dass ich scheiße wenn ich so oder
gucke ich da so also die fest kann ist
hier quasi so ich möchte lieber dass die
familie ist und so ein bisschen halt
noch von der seite keine ahnung die
nicht besser wenn ich dann halt auf
einem zweiten bildschirm drauf stellen
und ja das ist die lifecam hd 5000 von
microsoft direkt an dem ich das mit dem
windows live studio auf und die dich
voll geil die kann ich auch so drehen
also danke an simon der mir die da
empfohlen hat auf jeden fall
daumen hoch an sieht man die übrigen
heute geburtstag hat glaube ich
und ja das war es doch eigentlich schon
das wie gesagt dahinter liegt man usb
stick rum weil wir gerade schon gesagt
dass ich jetzt noch kaufen wollte waren
equalizer und kompressor für meine rote
mikrofone dann haben wir die komplette
professionalität
ich würde euch mal zeigen wie das da
oben auf meinem dingsda aussieht auf dem
auf meiner kameralistik schon wer der
geil aus und mitsamt micro drauf aber
googelt einfach nach diesem mikrofon und
moment hier sieht man es am besten da
wie das da oben ca drauf steht also oft
erkennen
und ja was ich euch noch sagen wollte
ist heute abend ist ein livestream von 8
bis 22 uhr mega projekt wird da gespielt
ich nehme davon eine folge auf und lag
die dann hoch und dann gehalt von 8 von
20 bis 22 uhr im livestream allem
ankündige ist früher an leute ist gerade
weiß ich nicht gespielt sechs uhr 7 uhr
wenn ihr dieses video seht ich hab's
euch eine stunde vorher angekündigt so
jetzt wisst ihr bescheid 8 bis 22 uhr
finde ich ist eine ganz menschliche leid
für alle die heute morgen schule haben
ich habe erst mittwoch wieder spiele
oder donnerstag mittwoch an dass sie
sind nach drei tage oder so auch mal
scheiße aber niemals samstag glaub ich
sogar heute samstag
heute samstag als bundesliga weiß und in
prägraten video nein
heute finde ich leite perfekt
samstagabend 8 bis 22 uhr ist perfekt
für euch eigentlich also das live stream
ich werde das gleich auch noch mal in
der mega projekt folgen sagen die ich
eventuell heute noch machen werde ich
weiß nicht oder ist konzert live stream
anstatt megaprojekt ja machen wir es
einfach so sagen sie heute kommt live
stream anstatt megaprojekt so ich werde
nochmal facebook post uns und
hoffentlich mit webcam versuche ich
hinzukriegen und dann
schreibt mir übrigens auch meinen namen
rein weil ich nach sowie loks wo ich
einfach bei ihnen was quatsch ich
brauche ihn von serien haben dafür sagt
nicht konstanz wie den astag aber
einfach so um solch ein paar infos mehr
näher zu bringen
das kommt da nicht halt in einem tag in
der woche ich könnte das kontakt machen
so sonntag aber nicht ich kann das doch
nicht machen sondern ich mache es
einfach mal immer so habe ich brauche
dann in diesem namen schreibt man dafür
die kommentare gibt norman hoch nicht
gefallen hat dass jetzt endlich
vernünftige face camp kommt immer und
tschüss